[Music]
hey Colonel Brian here very excited to
review Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 this
game comes out September 29th on ps4 and
Xbox one now it makes sense that I'd be
joined if I'm gonna play this game
by Tony Hawk himself and of course
hip-hop icon Lil Wayne I try to get into
the studio with you many times
yeah I may hang up on me yeah alright
Tony how did you two come together how
did you and uh we mostly through
skateboarding yeah so you're a
skateboarder
I skate I'm not a skateboarder have you
been hurt on the skateboard no you're
okay Wow
yeah this is an acid bump my god the
tattoos are fantastic how many do you
have and are you running out of room
yes I'm running out of room I don't know
how many out but I'm covered head to toe
have you ever thought of hiring an
assistant and starting to put tattoos
just on the assistant biggest thing you
say that because I didn't hire an
assistant to do it but some ideas that I
can't put on myself because I have no
room yeah I just give them to my
homeboys are my homegirls oh that's
great that's so essentially I was making
a joke you're really doing hiring people
and putting tattoos that you would like
to have but you're out of room exactly
all right why don't you take us through
it let's get started okay well first of
all you want to choose a skater that's
you you look you look good you're a
little dead in the eyes maybe no no no
no in real life you look fantastic
I'm just saying right there you look
killed some people in the Pacific
Northwest
Tony so you you put you put Wayne in the
game I never got a phone call what do I
have no Craig in the in the in the
skating community its beauty on this
building you don't remember how good I
am do you
I forget you don't remember the time I
caught air over you okay so this is you
Wayne how's it feel to watch yourself
and the dough because you better watch
Tony what is late coming out of your
crotch
the woman has the same question Tony can
I make suggestions yes game yes is there
a place where the avatar can go and get
snacks break through that window right
there and on the room there should be a
place to get the what do you think what
would you want I mean just throw out
ideas if you gotta but would you want
where's the hooker strip hooker strip
yes yeah you could go up the pole and
down the pole on the board you could you
know he's saying that's her she's so
easy to get me in gravis
at everything you're an incredible lover
it's gonna quickly quiz you Tony and
feel free waiting to jump in you tell me
what's escape move and what's a sexual
position you ready
front foot impossible move pop shuvit
skate move beef cheeks power slide sex
position yeah really yeah don't do it
Tokyo sandblaster are you sure it's not
a position Tokyo you think well first of
all you got to be in Tokyo to do it and
you have to have sandblast equipment if
you get those things hooked up and you
get a lady who's up for it I will attest
it's a fantastic experience
okay assume the position that is a moon
that's a scape move yeah how about this
one burial stiffy with a cross bone
grinder pivoted to twist her with a 180
finger shove finishing with manual
go-gurt
yeah so anyway you should get that stuff
into the game and get it in facts the
triangles grind X's jump okay but we're
not sure yeah and I want to go towards
the fire
[Applause]
that wasn't it that was an orgasm while
that was happening that was fantastic
Tony we're gonna do a very interesting
part of game called bighead what happens
here well your head continues to grow
and as long as you're doing tricks you
can keep it from exploding that is
fantastic and if you don't do a trick
soon it's going to explode it's getting
great really funny Wayne do you want to
see your head get big all right it's
time to get real stop screwing around
Wayne and I challenge you you will play
and then I will play the loser has to
get a tattoo of the other person's face
on their body okay so you will have to
find room for a Conan head and it's got
to be big I'm not talking about some
tiny little dot there's some space right
here and I can go right there smiling
and that would not hurt your career or
your cred at all to have a big smiling
Conan right there and if I lose which
isn't gonna happen I'll get a tattoo of
you on my body let's see what you got
oh look at that you're defying gravity
look at this look at this look at this
look at this this is incredible
oh the DC waist legs were shaken when
your legs were shaking after 18,000 turn
us into six okay here we go
what do I do I push that pushed trigger
trigger go yeah
[Applause]
hi guys today's may have a heights
really honey is the height I had look
really really understand the way you
just keep seconds left do something wait
now
[Music]
I'm a man of my word are you happy or
kind of horrified beyond any time I'm
with a lady now this is the what they're
gonna see coming out is it gonna help me
yeah okay Tony Hawk's Pro Skater five
drops on ps4 and Xbox one on September
29th you can do 367 so you can do 885
you can flap jacket you can squanto the
whole nine yards bring it on in the
onion with you is that something people
say no you didn't think so
they might now
[Applause]
[Music]